the united states says it's sharply
reducing its troop numbers in
afghanistan
and iraq by mid-january the deployment
will be cut
to two and a half thousand soldiers in
each country
president donald trump made a campaign
promise to end what he called
forever wars but the move has triggered
opposition both from leading republicans
and nato allies
the sun could be setting on the u.s
presence in afghanistan
american soldiers have been fighting
here since 2001
helping stabilize the country after
overthrowing taliban rule
but suffering over 2 000 deaths
over time troop numbers have waned now
outgoing president donald trump will
further reduce the number of soldiers
here
and in iraq in light of these tremendous
sacrifices
and with great humility and gratitude to
those who came before us i am formally
announcing
that we will implement president trump's
orders to continue our repositioning
of forces from those two countries by
january 15
2021 our forces their size in
afghanistan
will be two thousand five hundred troops
our force size in iraq will also
be two thousand five hundred as u.s
troop numbers dwindled extremists gained
in strength
this attack on kabul university last
week killed 22 people
it was claimed by the so-called islamic
state which has emerged as a rival to
the taliban
the taliban themselves have stepped up
their attacks on security forces and
civilians
violating an agreement that foresaw the
withdrawal of all u.s soldiers by may
next year criticism of the latest
drawdown
even came from within the president's
own party
i think it's extremely important here in
the next couple of months
not to have any earth shaking changes
with regard to defense and foreign
policy
i think a precipitous drawdown in either
afghanistan or iraq would be a mistake
in iraq the u.s military presence was
greatly reduced after the defeat of isis
in 2017
this has increased this way of
neighboring iran and militia groups
aligned with tehran
as u.s soldiers head home they could
risk leaving the field to america's
adversaries
let's go to brussels now and talk to our
correspondent terry schultz who has been
on the ground with nato troops in
afghanistan
terry i understand the head of nato has
expressed concern about the trump
administration's troop withdrawal plans
in iraq and afghanistan what more can
you tell us
that's right terry even before the
announcement was final secretary general
jens stolzenberg
put out a statement expressing the
closest that a norwegian diplomat comes
to being displeased he reminded the
united states
that the the presence in afghanistan is
conditions based
that means their precipitous withdrawal
right now when conditions are not being
met when they're still widespread
taliban violence
could mean leaving the country again
open to become
a terrorist haven secretary general
stoltenberg said
every country wants to bring its troops
home but the time is not now right
uh he also reminded the united states
that many nato soldiers
have fought and died alongside the
americans
has the trump administration terry
offered any strategic
justification for the drawdown in
afghanistan now
well it's not clear exactly what acting
defense secretary christopher miller
said
to secretary general stoltenberg in a
call they had on friday and
again a call earlier this week but
from press reports it seems that miller
did not exactly say to stoltenberg
that they were going to make this
announcement of the troop cuts
and this is really important because all
countries all of the the nato troops in
afghanistan
are to some extent reliant on
infrastructure provided by the united
states so this isn't really something
you want to leave
to a last-minute announcement what
effect
is this u.s drawdown in afghanistan
likely to have
terry on those other nato allies you
mentioned
yeah it's not like they can just pull
troops out of a sector where the united
states is
is deployed terry and that everyone else
will be fine
the united states was the first in it
provides a lot of this stability
in in which other troops operate not
just that but the
ngos civil society are all dependent on
the
security provided by these u.s troops
which are there both in a nato capacity
and
in a bilateral capacity there are there
are special operations forces no one
else has on the ground
so if this really happens and that
remains to be seen
um this will have a huge impact on nato
deployments and i'm sure that other
governments are having to look now at
what they're going to do with their own
presence on the ground
this is a very delicate time in
afghanistan with negotiations underway
between the taliban and the government
how could this draw down by u.s forces
change the stability of the situation in
afghanistan
well it certainly takes a lot of
pressure off the taliban
to negotiate and actually implement the
peace deal
that's now being discussed because as i
said before
the withdrawal was due to be conditions
based and that means that the taliban
needs to be living up to the peace deal
we have seen attacks continue even in
recent days even this week
and so if the troops pull out if the u.s
forces leave and they're followed by
other nato troops
the taliban doesn't have to comply with
this peace agreement
and as secretary general stoltenberg
warned they will have free reign of the
country once again
terry thank you very much for your
insights that was our correspondent
terry schultz in brussels